>> HEARDEN: We're now going to talk about
the Wave Editor and how it works, and in particular,
how to extend it with its extension mechanisms.
And we're joined over VC by our glowing sphere
of genius, Dan Danilatos, who wrote the editor.
So any difficult questions, I'm just going
to field off to him. So, just to give some
context by Wave editor, we mean the rich text
editor that runs in the browser and that sits
on top of the operational transform layer
that Wave provides. So, it's about editing
content using operations to describe the content,
applying operations that come in, and all
these operations are then just handled by
Wave and the network. So, in order to understand
why the editor is structured the way it is,
it's important to understand the goals that
were set out when writing the editor, and
this is probably the most concise description
that we can have which is it's a toolkit for
rich, extensible, real-time, collaborative
editing. So rich, as in rich text; it's extensible
in that you can add loads of programmatic
extensions to it; it's real-time, so it's
fast, it's live; and it's collaborative, which
means it operates on a distributed document
model. Now, you make local mutations; they
get sent out, incoming operations from a server
can come in and apply. So it enables having
a rich document model that is kept semantically
clean. The rendering is a completely separate
concern. The document model is separate, which
means it can be designed using a structure
that performs well under transform. And by
keeping the rendering separate, it means that
we can use proper semantic HTML. We can use
HTML the way it was meant to be used with
paragraphs, line breaks, list elements; all
the proper semantic mark up. The core parts
of the editor help abstract away browser quirks
as well. It gives a consistent API for adding
in editing behavior and there's an API for
building extensions to the editor, and these
extensions, we call "doodads". And the reason
that they're called doodads is because widgets
and gadgets are both names that were already
taken. So, when we say the editor, it's not
a completely clear definition of what that
is because it's an open, extensible system.
But usually, what we mean is the core framework
of the editor and the Wave of document model
underneath it, as well as a bunch of sort
of standard default features that are installed
like paragraphs, bullets, styling, maybe some
other doodads like image thumbnails and maybe
gadgets; but it's an open-ended set of features.
So, it's not--when we say the editor, it's
not a clear cut definition of everything that
encompasses. But yeah, the design goal is
that you can add in lots of extra features
and these features operate at the same level
as most of the core features in the editor.
So the first question that you need to address
when you're building an editor in a browser
is how much to use the browser's native support
for editing, which is called contentEditable.
And some web editors entirely let the browser
do everything, for example, the closure editor
that's used in Gmail. It's all based on contentEditable
so everything you type, the browser is doing
all the editing and updating the DOM natively.
Other web editors like Bespin, which is the
Mozilla editor, everything's handled programmatically,
so everything you type, it is JavaScript code
that's executing and updating the DOM. So
in Wave, the editor, it tries to strike a
balance between the speed and convenience
of letting the browser do its thing, but as
well as the application flexibility of handling
everything ourselves. So we try and leverage
what the browser does well. So fast typing,
selection support, moving the current around,
cut and paste, IMEs; these kinds of things,
we let contentEditable do its thing, but for
many other things, we handle them all programmatically.
So the editor is designed so that you can
strike a balance, you can do whatever you
want to do manually, or you can let the browser
do whatever you want by default. So it's kind
of content editable on a very tight leash.
So the bulk of this talk is now going to talk
about rendering the document model. So even
though this isn't really part of editing,
it's a core part of interacting with the editor.
So by rendering the document model, we mean
in Wave, the document model is this clean
semantic model, doesn't know anything about
HTML. It's just a representation of the document
and uses line elements to separate lines.
There's text, it's all wrapped in the body
element, and it's all very simple structure
and we use the XML part of the document for
structure like text and lines. But for stylistic
things, we don't use structural elements;
instead, we use annotations and you might
recall from other talks how annotations work.
We'll see some more annotations later in this
talk. So an example of this separation between
the logical model and the rendering comes
up when we try and extend the editor, for
example, with an image thumbnail. So here
is an example of an image thumbnail that we
might want to embed in the editor content.
And in choosing a logical representation for
the data in this model, we're free to choose
whatever representation we want. So in this
case, we represent everything structurally.
There's an image element with an attachment
attribute that will identify some image. Within
that image element is a caption element that
contains some caption text, but we're not
constrained to use something that will work
with HTML; we can use whatever data model
we want. And this simple, clean, logical model
then renders to some disgusting HTML, because
HTML is not at all designed for arbitrary
layout and drawing. So instead of having an
editor operate on HTML, which would mean logical
content looking like something on the right
which is ugly, the logical content is kept
clean and there's a whole rendering system
within the editor to render to arbitrary HTML.
So this correspondence between the logical
model and the rendering model is done by using
references between two trees. So, on the left,
we have a picture of what the logical content
might look like. In this case, just an image
element that contains one child, which is
a caption, the image element has an attribute
on it. On the right, its corresponding HTML
which is the big, heavyweight tree of elements
and the correspondence between these two trees
is kept with references from--bidirectional
references between various nodes in the tree.
So in this case, the image element maps to
some top level div and the caption element
maps to where it appears in the rendering.
So there's two main flows within the editor
just like, if you remember from the talk yesterday
about the Wave panel, there's two main control
flows which is when--sorry, two main data
flows from when data goes in the model into
the display and from when events happen in
the display, mapping them back to changes
in the model. And these flows are called rendering
and UI handling. If you look in the code,
the rendering is all done through a type called
node mutation handler. So anything that does
rendering, they're all node mutation handlers
and handling display events are done by what
are called node event handlers. So now we're
going to talk about the rendering flow. So
in that caption example, that was a fairly
simple mapping. And by simple, it means that
ancestral relationships are preserved. There
was a cap--there was an image element that
had a caption child in the corresponding HTML.
The rendering of the image was still an ancestor
of the rendering of the caption. The editor
permits more complicated mappings that don't
need to preserve that kind of simple relationship,
so one of the key examples is how we render
lines. So in the logical document, a line
is encoded as a line element followed by some
text, and then when we render that to HTML,
we want to use proper HTML mark up, so it's
text wrapped as a paragraph element. So how
on earth we do these more complicated mappings?
And in order to explain this in a bit more
detail, I'm going to introduce the concept
of local nodes, and local nodes are parts
of the logical document that are not considered
part of the persistent content. Local nodes
will only show up on--in the client that creates
them; they're not transmitted to the server.
It's just an extra overlay of extra information
within the structure of the document. So they
take up zero size, incoming operations that
touch the document just know how to apply
around these local bits of state. If you're
interested in the code that does it, there's
a classical persistent content and that contains
all the details of how to resolve conflicts
like server operations applying in places
where local nodes currently are. But these
local nodes of just some local overlaid state
is a key mechanism that's used in the editor
for doing rendering. So back to this example
of how do we render lines. The trick is to
apply some local nodes to the content to transform
it into an intermediate representation which
is more suitable for rendering. So in this
case, any text that follows a line element,
we take that entire chunk of text and wrap
it in a local node and you can identify local
nodes because they all start with "l:." And
once these local nodes are in place, it's
a much simpler mapping to map this to the
rendered HTML. So this end to end mapping--sorry,
that will come up on the next slide. So these
local nodes, you know, one of their main uses
is for an intermediate representation to assist
with rendering, but they can really be used
for anything. Arbitrary features that you
install in the editor can put in their own
local nodes wherever they want for, you know,
local bookkeeping specific to your feature.
So how is this local overlay of state, how
is this exposed? The document model supports
different views. And two of the main views
it exposes are the persistent view which exposes
just the content that is persisted on the
server, so just the content that is shared
with everyone else. There's the full view
which extends the state with all the local
nodes. There are some other views as well,
but they're not important for this talk. But
the key thing to take away is that the document
model is a view--based model where all these
different views are all overlaid on the same
state. So this diagram shows you the control
flow of what happens through this intermediate
representation. So on the left, there's the
persistent model and when line elements show
up in this persistent model, the corresponding
event handler for the line elements gets notified
of them. They--it wraps the blocks of text
that follow the line elements, wraps them
in these local paragraphs nodes. When these
local paragraph nodes show up, the renderer
for those nodes observes them and figures
out how to update the display with HTML that
will look like a paragraph. So these renderers
are kind of chained together through this
data flow. And the next thing I'm going to
talk about is annotations and how annotations
are rendered. So you might recall that annotations
are not structural parts of the document.
It's a separate data structure that sits alongside
the document. And the abstraction is that
for every item in the document, an item being
a character or an element style on one end,
for every item, there's a map of key value
pairs. So in this case, we have two ranges
of annotations that overlap. So annotations,
you know, can freely overlap and this makes
it not trivial to paint them because HTML
doesn't have any first class support for this
kind of abstraction. So, because annotations
are usually used for sort of more decorative
mark up, like style or just some extra metadata,
it's not always essential that every client
has to paint them and it's usually quite fine
for the clients to ignore annotations that
they don't know how to render, because most
of the key content is in the structure. So
in Google Wave and Wave in a Box, the kinds
of things that we use annotations for, we
use them for tracking cursor positions and
selection as you see multiple people editing
a document and you see their name next to
some location, that's done using annotations.
Links and spelling corrections, those are
done through annotations. Diff highlighting
looks so--they are used fairly extensively.
So because HTML has no abstraction that corresponds
in any way to these annotations that describe
or that apply it to items in the document,
it's not immediately obvious how to render
them. But the trick that we use is to use
these local nodes again as an intermediate
representation. So on this slide, you can
see an example logical model on the left,
and I should point out it's a slightly old
slide. You'll see Ps in there but we don't
have Ps in our logical model. Imagine that
they are the...and you can see a bunch of
annotations on them. So there's an annotation
on the misspelling of "haev." On the "this,"
there's a link annotation. And the design
rendering that we want, the way we want to
show it up in HTML is pictured on the right
where the misspelling has a red underline
on it, and at the right hand boundary of it,
there's a drop down there to correct it. So
how do we get there? And the trick is there's
a classical annotation painter. And what the
annotation painter does is it identifies spreads
and boundaries of regions of the document
that have--that share the same set of annotations.
So in those contiguous regions, it wraps them
and spreads and puts in boundary nodes that
indicate boundaries. So in this example, the
text H-A-E-V that was annotated as a misspelling,
the annotation painter has wrapped this with
a local node to identify it as a spread, and
it's put a boundary node after that identifies
that there was a change in the annotation
value there. So once all these decorating
local nodes are in place, you can see that
mapping these representation of spreads and
boundaries, mapping this to HTML that looks
like--that will give the rendering we want,
this is much more straightforward now that
we have this intermediate state.
So along with local nodes, there's the equivalent
concept for annotations. So local annotations
again, they're not persisted. They're sort
of overlaid onto the document content. They
behave just like regular annotations; you
can annotate any part of the document. The
key--the key difference that makes local annotations
special is that unlike persistent annotations,
local annotations don't have to use just primitive
values. So annotations is a key value pairs.
Local annotations are free to use any type
for the values, including object references
because they are not sent to the server, they're
not persisted; it's just local in their client
session. So this is very handy for a number
of UI features if they want to store state
in the document. So that covers very briefly,
that covers the rendering path and there are
just a couple of slides on the event handling
path. This diagram here gives you an overview
of the structure of the event handling flow
in the editor. Going from bottom to top, there's--the
editor responds to native browser events;
typing, clicking, pasting, and there's a layer
on top that normalizes these events and tries
to abstract away browser quirks and the different
event models that are on every browser. It
also makes the events a bit more semantic
in the context of editing, so it will interpret
events like selection movement and Enter being
pressed. This kind of events, it makes them
first class and it also routes the events
to the layer above. And above, there's a kind
of first class distinction between things
that do things programmatically versus the
things that let the browser do its thing with
contentEditable and then try and observe what
it did and synthesize operations out of that.
Now there's some other ones we call extractors.
So there's a few extractors built in, but
most things in the editor are done through
handlers, and handlers operate at the same
level as custom handlers that you add when
you add your own doodads. And yeah, handlers
observe events and mutate the document model
above it. Yeah, question?
>> What were the extractors again?
>> HEARDEN: There's--they'll show up in the
following slides, but the two main extractors
are there's a text extractor and a paste extractor.
>> So does these two extract the text that
the user is talking about?
>> HEARDEN: Yeah. So it's--rather than interpret
a browser event entirely manually, we let
the browser do something natively and then
observe what it did to--what it did to the
DOM and then interpret an operation
out of that.
>> So in this model, I say to the character,
the character produces read immediately and
then to post process it to find out what the
character was?
>> HEARDEN: Yes. So that will show up--that
example will show up in a couple of slides.
So yeah, this is just a bit more detail on
what those event layers are, but I've already
talked about it. So, this example--so I'm
now going to go through, I think, about five
quick examples of the flow of editing interaction
in the editor. First one being the 99 percent
case of just typing regular characters, and
again, the goal is to get--is to make it fast.
Even tiny bits of latency as you're typing
is very easily noticed. So this--so typing
events, we let contentEditable usually do
its thing. We schedule a time out to run a
little bit later to observe what the browser
and native editor does and extract operations
out of that. So this means that typing is
just as fast as it is in a native contentEditable
region. But that's only for very basic typing.
>> [INDISTINCT].
>> HEARDEN: More or less. Yeah. Yeah.
So for something a bit more sophisticated
like pressing Enter, where--yeah, Enter is
kind of handled specially. There's custom
logic that's registered in the paragraph doodad,
and this handles the event completely manually
by splitting a line, by putting in a line
element, and then the corresponding renderers
kick in after that. So the reason this example
is important is that the way Enter behaves
is different in paragraphs versus if you're
in bulleted list or a numbered list. And all
this behavior is done--in Wave editor, it's
all done completely programmatically. It's
all under application control and this just
demonstrates the flexibility of you can either
let the browser do its thing or you can have
complete application control. So paste is--paste
is an example of something that's a little
special. In order to protect the logical content
and to protect the rendering, we do need to
let the browser do a paste somewhere because
otherwise, we don't know what the paste is
going to be, but we don't want it to go directly
into the rendering because that might munge
it up. So paste is handled by moving the selection
to an off-screen element. The browser will
paste some content in there and then paste
is handled through an extractor. The thing
goes in and looks at what the browser pasted
in that off-screen element and interprets
that as Wave XML and makes the corresponding
logical insertions into the document. And
I should mention that this trick also lets
us do semantic paste where if you select some
content within a Wave document, then paste
it somewhere else within a Wave document,
it's not that the paste comes through as HTML
and we kind of have to reverse engineer what
was the Wave XML that went in there; there's
a special path that lets us preserve exactly
what semantic HTML that was used in that case.
So there's just two more examples, one is
a stylistic example. So when you hit Ctrl+B,
what happens? Again, we don't let the native
contentEditable editor handle this because
the native editors do all sorts of crazy stuff
to the DOM. Instead, there's a key handler
that's registered in the editor that handles
this and it's handled by using a style annotation.
So it annotates the logical content with the
region that's being selected and puts an annotation
on it and then the annotation painter kicks
in, puts in the spread nodes and the boundary
nodes. And there are registered paint functions
that paint this annotation using CSS style
attributes. And the last example, I'm not
going to explain anything about how it works
other than for IME keyboard input, this is
too hard to do programmatically so instead,
this is something that's let through to the
editor--let through to the contentEditable
native editor and then we extract what comes
up. Okay, so we're going well for time. Any
questions on content--yes?
>> What's IME?
>> HEARDEN: IME stands for Input M--something
Extension. Dan, what's the right...?
>> DANILATOS: Input Method Editor.
>> HEARDEN: Input Method Editor. It's for,
like, a multi-lingual--like talking in Chinese
or talking in...
>> So, our editors, we live around of actually
not the [INDISTINCT] well then, the issues
we have is it's just so slow to rebuild the
DOM. How did you guys solve--what do you do
when someone makes the change that comes across
the network as just one character, and you
know, you build a DOM.
>> HEARDEN: No, no, no. So everything is mutated
incrementally in place. So, in the case of
a remote operation coming in to insert a character,
that will get inserted in place in the logical
content. You might remember in one of the
earlier slides, the mapping between the logical
content and the rendering, there are these
bidirectional references between various nodes
so there's sort of intelligent, incremental
stuff that just makes incremental mutations
to the rendering. It's not completely rebuilt
all the time. Any other questions? Okay, great.
Maybe just take a quick--a quick one or two
minute break because the next talk, we're
going to go through building a doodad, which
is going to be fun. So I will just get that
set up. Okay, let's get back into it. Do a
lightning run through extending Wave content.
So we're going to build a doodad and give
you a flavor for the development process of
building a doodad as well. So, just one slide
here; most of this talk is going to be inside
Eclipse and inside something that just got
checked in yesterday or the day before, which
is called the Editor Test Harness. And so,
I'll give a quick tour of the editor test
harness, what it is, how to use it; and then
if there's time, I might just briefly describe
some examples of existing doodads that are
used within Wave. Then we're going to build
an example doodad, and the doodad we're going
to build comes from--there's a tutorial that's
now online, I think, that's quite in depth
and yeah, quite detailed; covers all parts
of how to write a doodad and how to add custom
behavior and custom renderings within the
editor. All right. So, the Editor Test Harness,
you can run it in a number of ways. I'll just--so,
if you have a recent update of the Mercurial
Repository main links, this is the library's
repository. There's a package in there, clienteditor.harness,
and within there, there's a launch configuration
you can run. When you run it, it will start
up GWT's hosted mode server and then you launch
that and you'll get an application that looks
like this, and what is on screen here. Most
of it doesn't fit too well on a narrow screen,
but here there are two editors on this page.
There's an editor here on the left. You can
see me typing here. So, on the left, there's
an editor operations that are coming out of
the editor and then getting applied to a second
editor over on the right just so you can have--it
gives you a mock environment of two concurrent
editors happening. You can edit in either
one; operations get propagated back and forth
between the two. Below the editor, you can
see here the logical content that is in yellow.
So here it's the document and the body element,
the line elements and the text within them;
and you can see that these are being--these
are being wrapped in some local nodes. You
can see the local paragraph elements here.
And on the right, you can see the HTML to
which that state has been rendered. So, here,
it's all divs and ULs, and line breaks and
things. And this mapping is--yeah, you can
see the correspondence between this rendering
and the logical content now that's being marked
up with local nodes. Now, there's lots of
buttons for doing fancy stuff. The main--the
main stuff that we're going to use is just
typing in one editor and there's also a--there's
also a field here where you can enter in the
logical content that you want to show up in
the editor just to help bootstrap development.
Okay, so the doodad we're going to build is
an image doodad that looks very much like
the image thumbnail doodad that's in Google
Wave. And what's in it--so it's an inline--it's
an inline image doodad. It's got an image
and it's got a caption within it that you
can type in. And so, we're going to--we're
going to have time to build the whole thing
from scratch but what I'm going to do instead
is point out the finished content and, like,
poke and prod it around a little bit. So,
there's two main--two main clauses here that
will be a concern. One is what's called the
entry point module. So, I know most of you
haven't done much work with GWT before, but
the unit of modularization in GWT is called
a module. And you build your application up
out of these GWT modules and you nominate
one module to be the entry point for your
application. So, this code here is just saying,
"Here's a module to be an entry point and
the minimum code that you need to get things
running." I clicked the right button this
time. That one. The minimum you would need
to get things running looks just like this.
You create and edit a harness object and you
just run it, and that's it. And if you do
that, you'll get the page that I just showed
you before. But in this tutorial, we've put
in a bunch of things to work with the doodad
that we're writing. And the doodad we're going
to write is called "my doodad" and the key
part of installing a doodad is typically a
static register method on the doodad that
accepts a registry into which it registers
its various parts. So, we're going to start
off from the very--so, from the very base
case, when there's nothing registered, what
happens--so now I'll just refresh the harness.
This is Eclipse—this is GWT's hosted mode,
code server running. It's recompiling the
application. So, if we put in the logical
content a reference to MyDoodad then what
shows up is a default rendering. And the default
rendering of doodad is just a gray box with
the name of the doodad typed in it. So if
you see this, this means that the default
renderer is kicking in, but what we want to
do is register our own renderer. So, simplest
case is here, we have a simple renderer. What
we do with it is to register that renderer
for the tag name of our doodad and the tag
name, in this case, is MyDoodad. And what
does that renderer look like? So this is that
renderer. You can see it extends a mutation
handler. That's not good. And the way it's
going to render the logical content of the
doodad is just to translate it to an HTML
image element, and that's this code here.
And it also responds to modifications of the--I
should point it out. The way we want to represent
the state of our doodad, to start of with,
this just has a reference attribute that points
to where the image is. So, in code, we just
translate that to the source attribute of
an HTML image element. So that's the simple
renderer.
So, if we write that and register that, these
doodads will start showing up like this. So,
it's just an HTML image. It wasn't that nice
and easy. So, the next thing we--we can do
is attach some behavior to this doodad. And
we're going to do that with a simple event
handler. And we have to register that event
handler. And the behavior we're going to add
is this code here. All we have to do is to
say that when the doodad gets activated, we've
registered a JavaScript event handler so that
when we click on it, it brings up a prompt
that will let us change the reference attribute
of it. So, that's all this code here. It's
pretty tight and compact. So I'm now installing
that handler. Refresh and see the next stage
of the doodad. To remember one of the...let's
try this doodad. So, we click on it and the
handler we registered is now being invoked.
And the code in our handler takes the value
that we put into this window prompt; updates
the ref attribute in the logical content,
and we'll see the renderer that we've registered,
the renderer kick in and update the rendering
by changing the source attribute of the HTML
image element. So, that's how--that's all
it takes to add custom rendering and event
handling to elements in the editor. The next
thing we're going to do is use some more sophisticated
rendering. And that...and yeah, I'll just...and
this more sophisticated rendering is going
to use a GWT widget to do the rendering. And
in the editor extension mechanism, if you
want to put in GWT widgets rather than just
native HTML, then there's a special mutation
handler that takes care of a lot of the GWT
hook-up for you. So in this case, we're running
a GWT renderer, and again, it has the same
sort of structure on modifications of the
ref attribute we translate them to modifications
of on the widget. So, that GWT widget itself--that
GWT widget itself is just--in this example,
it's just a stock standard Wave running a
GWT widget, there's a corresponding UI binder
template that just declaratively describes
the HTML. Before I go into any detail about
implementation of that widget...so now, we
should see a more sophisticated rendering.
So, it's a bit fancier, it's--you know, I've
got a beveled background for it. So, it's
using a GWT widget. Eclipse is going to die
on me now. Here we go. So, the next thing
is to attach--is attach the behavior again,
and to also think about starting to render
that caption element. So, within that--the
logical content, there is a caption element
with the image element. And how are we going
to render that? Let's see...that should do
the--that should do the trick. So, the key
thing to understand about having doodads for
composite structure is this concept of a doodads
container nodelet to this method here. So,
the usual case where you have a composite
structure that you want to render, in this
case, there's an image element--sorry, there's
a "MyDoodad" element that has a caption within
it. Usually, you want the rendering of the
child to be contained somewhere within the
rendering of the parent. And for this 99 percent
use case, there's a very simple way that you
can specify how to hook up the two renderings.
So you've got a rendering for the--for your
doodad which renders to that GWT widget I
showed you before. There'd be a separate rendering
for the caption element and there's some default
behavior that looks--when the editor is rendering
these two parts, it tries to look for where
to put the child within the rendering of its
parent and you can claim--you can declare
where you want it to go by overwriting this
container nodelet method. So, now we should
see the image with a rendering of a caption
in it. And there we go. So, this caption part
has been rendered by a separate renderer and
the editor knows how to hook it up using that
container nodelet mechanism. And there's only
one other--one next step that I wanted to
point out. So, by default--by default, if
you hook up a widget like this or hook up
a doodad like this, you'll typically run to
lots of usability issues, in particular, how
do you get--how do you get your carrot inside
that caption box? So, the editor has no way
of knowing, you know, how to do this for you.
So the default behavior that you'd see is
if you're before the image and you hit the
right arrow key, it's just going to jump all
the way over your entire image and jump down
to the text after it. But what we want to
do in this case is, one way, before the image,
if we hit the right arrow like I'll do now,
we want this behavior where the carrot is
placed inside the caption element. And similarly,
if you're at the end of the caption element
and you hit the right arrow, we want to have
the behavior where it'll put the cursor on
the right hand of the entire image. And this
is all quite simple to specify. There's a
caption event handler here. This isn't the
one I want. This is the one I want; this caption
event handler here. So, you might recall that
in the layering of the event flow in the editor,
there's a normalization layer. Part of that
is to express events in a language that is
more suitable for--it's more suitable for
an editing experience, and so it translates
it into events like handle left after node.
So, this event--this callback gets called
on your doodad when the carrot is after the
node and there's has been a selection event
of moving it to the left. And so, all we're
doing here, in this case, is saying if the
carrot is on the right of the entire image
thumbnail and the user hits the left arrow,
you want to move the carrot and put it at
the end of the caption, and that's this code
here, that's all it's doing. And similarly,
you know, if they hit right while they're--right
before the image thumbnail, I want to put--move
the carrot and move the selection inside the--inside
the caption. And then we get the behavior
that you can see here. You hit right, we're
in the caption and at the end of the caption,
things just keep flowing. And you can add--in
Google Wave, we add extra custom behavior
like for when you hit tab. When you hit tab
inside the caption, it will move to adjacent
captions and other image thumbnails. So these
kinds of things are all very easy to hookup
with the doodad API. So that's all that I
wanted to show you in code. There's only one
other thing that I wanted to talk about in
this talk and that's--so this is all--everything
you've seen so far has been structural which
is given XML elements, how to paint them,
how to handle events around XML elements.
What I haven't talked about at all is how
to register doodads, the control renderings
of annotations. So, the--like I mentioned
before, the annotation painter breaks up the
annotations into spreads and boundaries, and
those two abstractions of spreads and boundaries,
these are the abstractions that you use to
specify renderings, annotations. So there's
two kinds of functions you can register to
paint annotations, one is a regular PaintFunction
and that says for any region that is covered
by a particular annotation, apply these attributes
across the elements in that region. So, for
example, a bold annotation that covers some
text in a region, that gets--that annotation
gets rendered by a Piantfunction that puts
on a style attribute with font Wave bold.
The second of function is a BoundaryFunction
and these functions get invoked at the boundaries
where annotation values change. So, best example
of this would be the spelling--the spell correction
annotation, where the little dropdown arrow
that you see on the right of the text, that
gets rendered through a BoundaryFunction.
And a BoundaryFunction just specifies that
given a location where, on the left, the annotations
has one value and, on the right, annotation
has a different value; we can insert nodes
at that boundary. So, in the spell correction
PaintFunction or the spell correction BoundaryFunction
it says, "Where the value changes from..."
there is a spell correction here to--there
is no spell correction here. It inserts a
node at that location, and these are local
nodes that get inserted. So, that should explain
how you can specify paintings for annotations
using the doodad API. And we now have five
minutes for any questions. Do you have any
questions? Yeah, okay.
>> So if I want to, I can come up with my
doodad as [INDISTINCT] and start putting that
into my Waves then the--I need to have push
[INDISTINCT] that knows how to spread the
[inaudible], right?
>> HEARNDEN: It would be best to do that.
There's always a default rendering that kicks
in which you saw at the start where any doodads
where the other doesn't have painters or renderers
registered for them, just get rendered as
gray boxes. So it won't break someone else's
client, but they won't get a particularly
good experience. In the Google Wave client,
there's a whole separate system of extensions
where clients can install their own doodads,
like through your toolbars and various things.
But it's usually best to propagate the codes
so everyone has it. Anyone ready to write
their own doodads now? Yep? Okay, Darren (ph)
is there anything you wanted to throw in?
>> DARREN (ph): No, not much. That's basically
it. Just a couple of examples for use of annotations,
so the light bulb at the end of links is also
boundary in the wake. Selections, when you
see other people's selections, the little
blob that shows their name, that's another
boundary node as well. Yes, that's basically
it. But--and the other—the other thing to
point out is--while on that example we did
like an image search; it's a very widget kind
of example, basically, everything is written
with the same--so every single feature in
the editor like from paragraphs, bullets,
you know, image thumbnails, gadgets themselves;
yeah, links. Basically everything is done
with the same API. So, it's not just for building
widgets that respond to events, it's for arbitrary
editing functionality. That's all.
>> HEARNDEN: Oh, one last question?
>> [INDISTINCT].
>> HEARNDEN: Yeah, it's done using the same
API, yup.
>> [INDISTINCT].
>> HEARNDEN: Yup.
>> HEARNDEN: Yup, that's right. Yeah, so that's
the kind of--demonstrates that the API is
powerful enough to do a wide range of editing
features. All right, thank you very much.
sically everything is done with the same API.
So, it's not just for building widgets that
respond to events, it's for arbitrary editing
functionality. That's all.
>> HEARNDEN: Oh, one last question?
>> [INDISTINCT].
>> HEARNDEN: Yeah, it's done using the same
API, yup.
>> [INDISTINCT].
>> HEARNDEN: Yup.
>> [